comment inventer tizi ouzou en vacances
là le mec qui se prend pour un animateur
de colonie d afficher cette vidéo parce
que cette année c'est 365 derniers jours
sur youtube ont été les plus ouvre de
ces six dernières années j'ai envie de
revenir avec vous sur les moments qui
m'ont vraiment marqué cette année qui
ont qui ont vraiment fait extrêmement
plaisir et qu'ils seront des souvenirs
inoubliables semble avant pour la
plupart germaine simplement vous en dire
plus sur ces moments là vous dire
pourquoi ça a été si important à mes
yeux pour que c'était vraiment génial
et encore une fois merci parce que
vraiment je ne suis jamais autant amusé
sur youtube c'est complètement ouf
grâce à vous je vis de ça je peux faire
ce que je veux sur ma chaîne je me suis
pas enfermée dans un type de vidéos vous
êtes super ouvert à aux vidéos que je
fais et des fois je fais des trucs
qu'ils soient un peu des ovnis qui sont
différents et vous appréciez vous même
vous me donner du courage en fait non
dit [ __ ] c'est cool ça change du port
faire c'est sympa voilà j'ai cette
chance c'est pas tout le monde qui a
cette chance sur youtube donc vraiment
merci beaucoup de ça fait maintenant un
an et deux mois que j'ai un studio et je
suis arrivée là dedans juste avant le 3
2016 avec lui on est allé avec cyprien
du mieux etc
je suis arrivé j'ai fait des petites
photos dont il n'y avait pas de mousse
isolante ici j'étais tout content
j'étais comme un gamin
et puis je me suis barré à los angeles
pour le 3 donc j'étais encore plus
content
je suis rentré le 3 et faisait beau tout
ça on faisait des vidéos gaming comme
d'habitude compilation des petits jeunes
awa guèye petit quizz tout ça et puis
pokémon go arrive aux yeux collés à leur
smartphone les joueurs marchent 10h
d'estivé tout nous dire sur ce jeu
pokémon ingo qui s'est répandue depuis
ce début d'été comme une traînée de
poudre à travers le monde ça n'existait
qu'en japon et aux etats-unis mais voilà
les pokémon débarque à paris le buzz est
colossal tout le monde en parle tous les
médias en prennent ça et on se dit avec
clément qui m'aident à cadrer à monter
les vidéos
bon on va peut-être faire un truc un sou
pokémon goût mais pas un truc de merde
vous faire un truc grands marrons et on
se dit vas-y on va partir dans la rue
jouais un personnage un chasseur
complètement égocentrique et qui qui ce
qui est sûr de lui qui se la pète kéké
insolent au décide alors de faire cette
première vidéo un petit peu à la rage
tellement à la rage qu'on se fait choper
par la dgse à la fin est là on met ça en
ligne et c'était le début des vidéos un
peu différente on ose aller dehors on
oser sortir du bureau et ça vous a
extrêmement plus et je regarde un
souvenir mémorable parce que ça m'avait
vraiment fait chaud au coeur et ça
m'avait donné beaucoup dans vie pour
tous cas les suivre aussitôt la vidéo
sorti aussitôt jeudi à clément [ __ ]
mais il faut qu'on remettre ça c'était
trop marrant en plus on prend on voit
dehors on sent un peu du sud c'est
vraiment cool les salaires ça plaît
énormément aux gens et je me dit vas-y
on va passer l'étape du dessus à verser
dans un véhicule électrique on sort la
vidéo accuse véhicule électrique vous
adorez je me dis bon bah là y'a plus
qu'à gérer les pokémon eau et puis les
pokémon r on pourra pas parce qu'un
hélicoptère
c'est chaud bref c'était des vidéos qui
ont vraiment fait plaisir à faire et qui
ont marqué je trouve un petit peu ce
nouveau départ il ya un an même vous
c'est ce que vous me disiez c'est vrai
maintenant je me rends compte
c'était vraiment chouette un mois plus
tard je décide de rejoindre mon frère en
colombie qui était lui en road trip avec
sa copine depuis 7 mois est rentrée en
septembre et sa copine voulait
absolument qu'on lui fasse la surprise
que je vienne sans rien lui dire bon en
vrai il avait un petit peu grillé mais
quand même ils étaient y étaient surpris
ça comme marcher je décide alors de
faire deux trois vidéos d'avancer et de
me dire vas-y il sera en road trip
pendant sept mois qu'une seule fois dans
sa vie j'aurai l'occasion de le
surprendre comme ça avec une seule fois
dans ma vie alors c'est parti et ce
voyage m'a beaucoup rapproché de mon
frère et c'est en partie grâce à vous
parce que à l'enclos lui ça coûte des
thunes un l'avion le séjour de ça ça
coûte de l'argent et comme je le disais
au début de la vidéo je vis et je vis
très bien grâce à youtube aujourd'hui et
ça me permet de faire des trucs aussi
ouf que ça de rejoindre mon frère comme
ça sans devoir me prendre quatre mois al
avance réfléchir mettre de l'argent de
côté et tu sais j'ai cette chance et
j'en ai profité et
merci du fond du coeur parce que c'était
un truc dont on se souviendra toujours
pas d'ailleurs on l'a marqué sur notre
peau en se faisant tatouer un [ __ ] de
le même crabe tous les deux c'est
inoubliable c'est magique ce que j'ai
vécu là-bas en plus j'ai découvert
l'amérique était une destination qui me
faisait pas spécialement envie et j'ai
découvert une culture que je connaissais
pas avant et que j'ai adoré la seule
déception c'était quelqu'un j'ai dû
partir pour revenir sur paris faire des
vidéos etc mettent en ligne mon frère a
à ce moment là aller aux caraïbes est vu
comme ça mais normalement et qu'on adore
se [ __ ] le sommes il m'envoyait des
photos de lui aux caraïbes et mec
[ __ ] j'aurais tellement dû rester deux
jours de plus perdre mais c'est pas
grave on s'est rattrapé plus tard et là
c'est la rentrée scolaire septembre
octobre novembre mois bizarrement je me
cale encore sur la rentrée scolaire
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que je fais
cette vidéo bilan des 365 derniers jours
à la moitié d'année 2010 est c'est pas
logique j'ai rarement les gens foncent à
fin 2017 pour parler de l'année 2007
mais moi je suis encore en année
scolaire dans ma tête je suis un peu con
donc là septembre octobre novembre ont
fait des vidéos essentiellement dans le
studio voire même que dans le studio je
crois sur du jeu vidéo sur des coups
sûrs des gens nus avec des potes sont
des jeux société j'en sais rien mais ça
m'amuse et en descente je me dis [ __ ]
en 2014 j'ai fait un sp sur la ligne
désolation les gens avaient adoré en
2015 j'ai fait un essai sur internet les
gens avaient encore plus adoré cette
année j'ai envie de faire les deux
plaies mais j'ai pas envie de faire sur
un jeu d'horreur et depuis quelques
années je suivais un petit peu de plus
ou moins près la sortie de the last
guardian de tricot [ __ ] et j'ai peur
parce que je me dis bon c'est un let's
play c'est un jeu qu'à l'air hyper long
c'est pas du tout un jeu d'horreur ya
pas deux c'est pas mouvementée c'est pas
du gameplay ouvert
c'est assez fermé comme until the end
sauf cas pas le côté scénario flippant
de till dawn
mais je trouve que le jeu est d'une
beauté exceptionnelle que ça va changer
justement des deux aspects que j'avais
fait avant et je me lance je me lance je
me dis allez c'est parti pour le fais au
pire ça marche pas c'est pas grave mais
j'ai trop envie de faire découvrir se
jaugeant et de l'heure de leur faire
ressentir ses émotions que moi même j'ai
ressenti en y jouant et puis surprise
gros carton vous surkiffé the last
guardian et ça m'a fait chaud au coeur
de housses et ça rejoint ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure que j'ai la chance
de pouvoir faire ce que je veux sur la
chaîne youtube
il y aura la majorité des gens qui
regarderont et qui qui aimeront enfin
bref merci pour ça c'était génial
à l'heure actuelle presque tous les
épisodes ont passé la barre des 2
millions de vues ce qui est énorme pour
des vidéos comme ça et même au delà de
ça je me suis vraiment rendu compte de
l'impact que cette se plaire avait eu
quand les gens qui me reconnaissaient
dans la rue
le joaillier sur des conventions me
disait [ __ ] make the last guardian
j'ai adoré quand des potes de la vraie
vie plus vieux que moi me disait [ __ ]
ma femme elle elle regarde tout le temps
on the last guardian elle suit ça comme
une série [ __ ] ça me faisait super
spéciale je me disais ah ça touche un
peu un nouveau public mais ça plaît
quand même à mon public actuel est ce
assez rare en fait bref l'expérience
était géniale du coup j'ai la pression
parce que je me dis au prochain ait fait
ça va être difficile de faire aussi bien
voire mieux mais on va essayer le 18
décembre je m'enligne le dernier épisode
du let's play de sur the last guardian
je pleure parce que c'est la fin du jeu
mais surtout parce que la fin du jeu
elle est hyper triste et je décide de
partir en corée pendant dix jours payés
que j'avais déjà fait au début de
l'année en mars quand j'étais allé au
japon j'ai déjà avait fait un petit
détour pendant trois jours en corée et
j'avais beaucoup aimé
donc je voulais retourner passer
beaucoup plus de temps là bas les
vacances en tant que youtube heures
comme ça c'est pas des vacances à 100%
parce que tu filmes et tu vas me faire
des montages le soir pour mettre en
ligne ces deux derniers jours passant
encore et enfin c'est c'est très
particulier mais moi ça me convient dans
le sens où je j'arrive quand même à
profiter à fond de là où je suis tout en
faisant profiter aussi les gens du cadre
des activités que je fais donc c'est
cool là encore et je m'étais fait mon
deuxième tatouage par hugues haute à
thouars un très très bon tatoueur qui
est d'ailleurs passé sur paris il n'ya
pas longtemps dans un salon pendant dix
jours et qui m'a fait un autre tatouage
juste ici voilà c'était super marrant de
le revoir sur paris alors je l'avais vu
encore est l'un des rares fois qu'on
s'était vu c'est ça c'est marrant
j'avais tiré avec une arme à feu pour la
première fois de ma vie j'avais mangé
des poissons qui ressemblaient à des
pénis j'avais été dans un bain public
pour la première fois nue au milieu
d'autres hommes nus c'est totalement un
truc qui se fait énormément là bas après
une grosse journée taf ils vont la base
des tentes dans des eaux à 41 et 43
degrés ils sont bien tous les apôtres
monde s'en fout je termine mon séjour
sur un nouvel an a donc des le quartier
que je vous ai montré même temps dont
une ou plusieurs vidéos je croise mon
quartier préféré c'est un quartier très
jeune trip steurs et à ongles et c'est
là où yab presque tous les tatouages
c'est là où les jeunes sont assez de
décomplexer et même les vieux sont le
sont plus qu'ailleurs et tu as honte d
entourer par un maximum de corée un feu
d'artifice et je me dis [ __ ] c'est en
train de vivre un nouvel an dans un
autre pays que le mien je suis en train
de vivre ça en corée en plus des gros
fêtard là bas donc c'était vraiment
grosse ambiance était super puis je
rentre en france au pas pour continuer
les petites vidéos gaming divers et
variés jusqu'au mois de février ou mamie
twin que j'apprécie énormément me
propose de faire une exploration
nocturne avec lui dans un lieu en plus
ce qui m'attirait beaucoup les
catacombes interdite de paris c'était
i inoubliable c'était vraiment une
ambiance particulière c'était à la fois
effrayant mais à la fois excitant et
écoulent en fait ça s'est super bien
passé et à un moment on est resté dans
les catacombes pendant plusieurs heures
et un mois je me souviens ont été posées
dans un petit un militant elle vraiment
où on devait être un peu baissé comme ça
assise et et on a discuté pendant des
dizaines de minutes sans se rendre
compte qu'on était ou dans l'endroit le
moins confortable du monde en fait un
thé coupée du monde et dans ta bulle et
on s'est arrêté en plein air en plein
milieu de l'expression nocturne pour
discuter d'un meeting qui a pris une
petite photo je suis d'ailleurs repartis
plus tard avec 20,8 ring qui a offert de
l'urbex dans un hôpital abandonné
c'était très sympa beaucoup plus
horrifique que les catacombes mais ça
s'est bien passé et [ __ ] c'est
toujours un plaisir mamie trucks et
l'adorable un peu plus tard le même moi
je fais j'ai encore du mal à réaliser ce
qu'il fait jour là tellement c'est
dingue je visite
l'agencé spatiale européenne en
allemagne à cologne grâce à mon
influence et donc grâce à vous encore
une fois j'ai en fait je n'ai jamais
parlé j'ai des patients à bruz dont je
parle pas dans mes vidéos et l'espace en
fait partie j'ai toujours été fasciné
par le fait qu'on soit des petits grains
de sable dans l'univers conçoivent rien
que notre planète est un grain de sable
je trouve ça incroyable à l'occasion
j'amène avec moi un ami qui s'appelle
abdel un ami du collège et il sait et
qui lui étaient encore en étude et je
lui dis il est photographe donc je me
dis bon et pourra me cadrer sa frappe le
job est pourquoi je le choisis lui parce
que c'est un mec encore plus passionné
que moi par l'espace du coup on y va
ensemble en train on passe la journée la
balle deux jours même s'étaient tous les
deux ont fait des débris le soir on pose
dix mille questions sur place ont été
vraiment à fond et il a pu écrire un
mémoire sur sa d'ailleurs grâce à vous
du coup vous l'avez mis bien cousin
[ __ ] le 6 mars c'est le lancement de
la web tv le stream [ __ ] ça faisait
des années qu'on en parlait avec mika
avec cyprien on lance enfin le truc
c'était beaucoup de tables c'était
épuisant mais maintenant c'est là le
seul point fr c'est là et j'interviens
défendant des émissions on s'éclate que
ce soit sur les prime ou des émissions
sur du game et au juste les croiser dans
les bureaux ça me fait plaisir je suis
super que dans ce projet mais après le
lancement j'étais fatigué et quand tu es
fatigué tu fais quoi tu prends des
vacances
eh bien là c'est juste le meilleur
souvenir de ma life que j'ai fait j'ai
pu payer un voyage de deux semaines au
japon à mon frère et à mon père on est
partis entre hochart ça faisait trop
entendu à mon frère que je voulais
l'emmener au japon et c'est un truc qui
cf
et grâce à l'argent que génère machine
youtube clairement qu donc grâce à vous
qui regardez les vidéos et qui généré
cet argent j'ai pu offrir le plus beau
cadeau que je pouvais offrir à ma
famille c'est à dire des souvenirs c'est
quelque chose toute notre vie on s'en
souviendra même quand je les vois à
l'heure actuelle on ressort des
anecdotes du japon et je sais que ça les
a marqués ça m'a marqué aussi on a dormi
dans une caravane au plus proche du mont
fuji on a vu un lever de soleil
magnifique au dessus de ce dernier on
s'est baigné dans des sources chaudes
naturelles à hakone on a dormi dans un
hôtel traditionnel japonais ce qu'on
appelle un ryokan on a pu fabriquer nos
propres nouilles les mêmes qu'on se
faisait des années plus tôt le midi au
lycée qu'on avait deux heures pour
manger on a visité plein de monuments
des temples et des tampons dans la
bouffe et on est allé dans un petit café
à charbon on a joué des heures et des
heures as they can dance à l'arcade je
suis allée chez le coiffeur votants
échoué en violet lancer ensemble à huy
un truc important aussi et que j'adore
avec youtube c'est que ça crée des
amitiés tu rencontres des gens géniaux
comme par exemple récemment mcfly
carlito avec qui on a fait plusieurs
vidéos ensemble mais à l'époque j'étais
en partie au japon j'ai rencontré
maxence qui est un très bon ami à seb et
je voyais ça avec maxence était là et à
l'heure actuelle c'est devenu un très
bon ami on a fait cette vidéo de merde
là où doit faire du bruit pour faire
avancer un perso le faire sauter
pourquoi je souligne sa dans cette vidéo
c'est parce que depuis en fait je parle
énormément avec maxence on bosse sur
plusieurs trucs et en fait ça me permet
de d'avoir un petit peu de changements
dans ce que je fais au quotidien de
bosser sur des trucs un peu plus gros
annexes avec son aide de bosser à 2 fin
c'est un truc que je fais pas
habituellement moi mes vidéos c'est que
de l'improvisation je suis généralement
seul devant mon ordi mais ça me fait du
bien à voir ça à côté de manière
régulière donc merci maxence à mon
retour du japon le 7 avril je mets en
ligne
la overweight strap battle projet qui a
acquis un prix [ __ ] des mois et des
mois de travail c'est le plus gros
projet vidéo que j'ai fait sur la chaîne
youtube
à l'heure actuelle franchement j'en suis
très fière et l'expérience que ça m'a
apporté c'est dingue c'est 110 niveau
d'un coup d'envoi d'un fort creux
vraiment mais bon au final même si je
pouvais plus écouter le son de ce que
j'avais déjà l'écouter au 800 mille fois
et le clip pareil j'avais eu 6 en
version avant la version finale donc je
ne pouvais plus blairer cette vidéo
avant même de la met en ligne ce génial
au final dames et en ligne des premiers
retours assez négatif les gens étaient
un peu déçus jeu tetris musée [ __ ]
merde
je me suis donné les moyens de faire ce
truc tout le monde m'a aidé tourne a été
cool avec moi to m'a soutenu et merdes
s'appelait pas [ __ ] et en fait c'est
comme j'ai remarqué que généralement
quand il tu perçois une chanson sur
youtube les premiers retours sont assez
négative
et puis après ça se tasse savent aller
retours positifs sont là manière
régulière il ya plus aucun retour
négatif ça c'est bizarre au final en
trois mois la vidéo a fait 15 millions
de vues c'est là l'une des vidéos les
plus vues de ma chaîne youtube blizzard
l'a même mis dans leur launcher battle
net
aux us donc à des anglais qui sera menée
sur la vidéo et qu'ils aient [ __ ]
c'est en france et casse les couilles je
quitte merci les anglophones
j'ai même vu des mecs se clasher avec
des onglets dans les commentaires en dix
ans mais avec la vidéo et en français
mais y'a les sous titres anglais nous
les neuf dixièmes des trucs ou regarde
c'est en anglais et sous titres en
français on casse pas les couilles fait
vous êtes des toques [ __ ] star foule à
l'agression et le mois suivant en avril
je vis le truc le plus fou de toute ma
vie je fais un volant zéro g c'est la
suite de la vidéo à l'agencé spatiale
européenne je fais un vol en zéro g et
[ __ ] c'était l'expérience la plus
folle de ma vie comme le titre l'indiqué
c'est terrible parce qu'à l'heure
actuelle je me souviens déjà plus de ce
que ça fait d'être en en zéro g je me
souviens plus mon cerveau a oublié je me
suis de nouveau complètement habitués à
la gravité j'ai même plus conscience
gars de la gravité tout comme vous mais
je sais que sur le coup j'étais bouche
bée et je me disais [ __ ] le paradis ça
doit être ça doit être un truc comme ça
et deux mois plus tard on en est à
aujourd'hui ya deux gros projets dans
les cartons dont l'un des deux qui sort
peut-être la semaine prochaine en fin de
semaine prochaine ou celle d'après mais
j'espère en fin de semaine prochaine et
l'autre qui sortira beaucoup plus tard
et qui ne sera pas un projet youtube
mais qui est très cool et maxence mettre
dessus d'ailleurs et c'est super c'est
un truc au long terme qui te permet de
faire autre chose que de youtube et qui
te fait kiffer enfin bref on a fait le
tour de cette rétrospective sur 7 365
derniers jours qu'ils étaient les plus
forts de ces six dernières années sur
youtube pour moi merci je pense que la
berd et conclusion c'est juste dire
merci je suis hyper ému de voir à quel
point vous pouvez soutenir quelqu'un
sans même le connaître personnellement
en fait je vous remercie pour tout ce
que vous avez fait pour moi pour tout ce
que vous m'avez permis d'offrir à des
gens et même à ma famille à mon frère
mon père ma mère ma grand mère alors
attention j'ai pas marché du tout hein a
atterri dans cette vidéo tout est beau
tout est rose tu payes tous parfaits je
mes défauts comme tout le monde même des
fois sur youtube j'ai fait de la merde
du truc con ça arrive à tout le monde de
faire des erreurs mais
m toujours même malgré mes avoir soutenu
et est suivie et je trouve ça dingue
donc je vous remercie j'essaie de rester
humain et moi-même à z les gens adorent
dire cette phrase est surtout change pas
en reste comme ça à frère ou alors a eu
la meilleure c est franchement t'arrête
pas t'arrête pas c'est trop mignon comme
phrase mais moi quand tu dis ça je me
dis juste mais j'ai jamais parlé d'
arrêter b dont je veux parler des coups
que tu veux que j'arrête nom génial ben
voila j'ai dit tout ce que j'avais à
dire pire je me suis vidé ça me fait du
bien je me suis vidé là j'avais trop
bien ça fait très longtemps en fait je
faire cette vidéo bas deux mois en fait
juste après le vol zéro-g je voulais la
faire et [ __ ] ça fait du bien quand ça
sort ça fait du bien de revenir sur tout
ça de se rendre compte qu'on a avancé qu
on a fait des trucs vraiment cool cette
année et puis j'espère que cette année
je revivrai des trucs aussi riche et
intense en tout cas je vais tout faire
pour j'espère que la grosse vidéo qui
sort la semaine prochaine ou la semaine
d'après on va vous plaire et puis je
vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine
vidéo où on va finir sur un truc très
simple même si j'ai déjà dis merci
beaucoup